Hey there, Shankar here. We've spent the last several weeks exploring a series of ideas about how you can use social science research to make your life better. If you've missed those episodes, go back and listen to them. We've looked at how you can make work more meaningful, the importance of limiting distractions, and a scientifically proven technique to achieve your most important goals. Today's episode is the last one in the series. We first put it out and January this year. It asks a very important question. If you happen to find yourself in a blind alley, nowhere to turn, you're frustrated, dejected,
你好，我是尚卡尔。过去几周，我们一直在探讨一系列关于如何利用社会科学研究来改善生活质量的观点。如果你错过了之前的节目，请回去听一听。我们探讨了如何让工作更有意义、限制干扰的重要性，以及一种经科学验证的实现最重要目标的方法。今天的节目是该系列的最后一期。我们最初是在今年一月发布的。它提出了一个非常重要的问题：如果你发现自己陷入了死胡同，无路可走，感到沮丧、灰心，
what psychological techniques can help you get unstuck? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Many of us feel we are not leading the lives we were meant to lead, that we're not living our dreams, that life is passing us by. This sense of doubt leaves many of us feeling rudderless, confused, and stuck. I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. Today we're going to explore the psychological traps we construct for ourselves that keep us from living our best lives.
有哪些心理技巧可以帮助你摆脱困境？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们许多人觉得自己的生活并非本该有的样子，觉得没有实现梦想，觉得生活正在从身边溜走。这种怀疑感让我们许多人感到迷茫、困惑和停滞不前。我给自己施加了很大的压力，以确保我做出了完全正确的决定。今天，我们将探讨我们为自己设置的心理陷阱，这些陷阱阻碍了我们过上最好的生活。
For many years, Christine Metzger thought she knew what she wanted to do with her life. But after more than a decade working in education administration, she woke up one day and realized she wasn't the person she wanted to be. She didn't know exactly who she did want to be. But she was certain that that ideal version of Christine was out there. She just had to find her. She stumbled on what seemed like the perfect opportunity, developing a coaching program for teachers at a boarding school in England.
多年来，克里斯汀·梅茨格以为她知道自己想要什么样的生活。但在教育管理部门工作了十多年后，有一天她醒来，意识到自己并不是她想成为的那个人。她并不确切知道自己想成为谁。但她确信，那个理想中的克里斯汀就在某个地方。她只需要找到她。她偶然发现了一个看似完美的机会，即为英国一所寄宿学校的教师开发一个辅导项目。
She took the plunge. She quit her job, sold her belongings, and prepared to embark on her new life. I was sleeping on an arrowbed and had my three suitcases next to me. I was right about to literally leave Hoboken and be on my way. And I received a phone call from the folks in England saying, we're really sorry, but we couldn't get you a work visa. Instead of heading to England for her dream job, Christine found herself unemployed.
她决定放手一搏。她辞掉了工作，卖掉了财产，准备开启新生活。我当时睡在充气床上，三个行李箱就在旁边。我正准备离开霍博肯，踏上旅程。结果我接到了英国那边打来的电话，说：“真的很抱歉，但我们没能为你办下工作签证。”克里斯汀没能去英国从事梦想的工作，反而失业了。
Still in search of that ideal career, the next position she found didn't have visa issues. She would be working for the American Bible Society as liaison to the president. Even better, he had personally asked her to apply for the job. It was a long process and unfortunately in the end it turned out that the the organization had a hiring freeze, and the board did not give permission to hire me and actually eventually the president ended up leaving
在继续寻找理想职业的过程中，她找到的下一个职位没有签证问题。她将为美国圣经协会工作，担任主席联络员。更好的是，主席亲自邀请她申请这份工作。这是一个漫长的过程，不幸的是，最终该组织冻结了招聘，董事会没有批准录用我，而且实际上主席最终也离开了
that company and I was left in a lurch one more time and in a transition that I wasn't expecting or planning on. It wasn't just losing the job that bothered Christine. A nagging fear was growing at the back of her mind. She started to worry. She wasn't even on the right track. The next job came, working for a nonprofit organization in the performing arts.
那家公司，我再次陷入了困境，处于一个我没有预料到或计划到的过渡期。困扰克里斯汀的不仅仅是失去工作。一种挥之不去的恐惧在她脑海深处滋长。她开始担心自己甚至根本没有走在正确的轨道上。下一份工作来了，是在一家表演艺术非营利组织工作。
This one, she got. And then another transition came a little earlier than I anticipated. Christine was downsized. In fact, on the day she and I talked, Today is my last day at the organization. Christine couldn't understand it. Here she was, a smart, talented woman with years of experience,
这份工作她得到了。然后，又一次过渡比我预期的来得早了一些。克里斯汀被裁员了。事实上，就在我和她交谈的那天，她说：“今天是我在该组织的最后一天。”克里斯汀无法理解。她是一个聪明、有才华、经验丰富的女性，
and inside, she felt like a rudderless college freshman. The pressure to discover her ideal life weighed heavy on her. And I think for most of my life I had that sense of when I'm looking for work or if I was in a transition. I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. Turns out Christine is not alone. Lots of people feel the way she does. Lost and stuck. They
但在内心深处，她感觉自己像个迷茫的大一新生。发现理想生活的压力让她感到沉重。我想我一生中大部分时间都有这种感觉，当我在找工作或处于过渡期时，我给自己施加了很大的压力，以确保我做出了完全正确的决定。事实证明，克里斯汀并不孤单。很多人都有她这种感觉。迷茫且停滞不前。他们
beat up on themselves because they not only feel they aren't getting where they want to go, they don't know where they want to go in the first place. Psychologists in South Hat gurus have tried different kinds of advice for people like Christine, but recently we heard a new idea from an unlikely source. Silicon Valley. It turns out that engineers and designers in the tech world often face similar challenges when it comes to designing new products. How do you build something when you don't know what to build? Dave Evans used to work at Apple. One challenge he faced was in designing a new mouse. Should we have one button on the mouse or two buttons on the mouse?
责备自己，因为他们不仅觉得没有达到自己想去的地方，而且一开始就不知道自己想去哪里。南哈特古鲁的心理学家们尝试过为像克里斯汀这样的人提供各种建议，但最近我们从一个意想不到的来源听到了一个新观点：硅谷。事实证明，科技界的工程师和设计师在设计新产品时经常面临类似的挑战。当你不知道要建造什么时，该如何建造呢？戴夫·埃文斯曾在苹果公司工作。他面临的一个挑战是设计一款新鼠标。鼠标应该有一个按钮还是两个按钮？
They've said that he and Steve Jobs and other Apple engineers quickly figured out they really had two problems to solve. The first was to understand how people interacted with a computer to see what kind of a mouse would work for them. Before you do problem solving, you have to do problem finding. What's the right thing to be working on? To say it another way, the first challenge for the engineers was in figuring out what the problem was that they had to solve.
他们说，他和史蒂夫·乔布斯以及其他苹果工程师很快意识到，他们实际上有两个问题要解决。第一个是了解人们如何与计算机交互，看看什么样的鼠标适合他们。在解决问题之前，你必须先发现问题。什么是值得努力的正确方向？换句话说，工程师面临的第一个挑战是弄清楚他们必须解决的问题是什么。
The second challenge was to solve it. Apple founder Steve Jobs thought he knew the answers. But the designers wanted to find out what was actually best for users. They built a couple of prototypes. Now a prototype isn't just a model. It's a psychological tool. We reveal the assumptions we make that are probably wrong.
第二个挑战是解决它。苹果创始人史蒂夫·乔布斯以为他知道答案。但设计师们想找出对用户来说真正最好的方案。他们制作了几个原型。现在，原型不仅仅是一个模型。它是一个心理工具。我们揭示了我们所做的可能错误的假设。
We get to, as we call it, sneak up on the future and involve other people with your ideas. It turned out, people preferred one button. Now, figuring out how to build a mouse with only one button was a complicated engineering problem. But at least now, the engineers knew where they were trying to go. Lots of people in Silicon Valley called this approach design thinking. A few years ago, Dave says he realized that design thinking might be useful outside the tech world too. He started teaching a course at Stanford University called designing your life. In the class, Dave talks about how everyday life produces challenges that are actually
正如我们所说的，我们可以“潜入未来”，让其他人参与到你的想法中来。事实证明，人们更喜欢一个按钮。现在，弄清楚如何制造一个只有一个按钮的鼠标是一个复杂的工程问题。但至少现在，工程师们知道他们要往哪里走了。硅谷的许多人称这种方法为“设计思维”。几年前，戴夫说他意识到设计思维在科技界之外也可能有用。他在斯坦福大学开设了一门名为“设计你的生活”的课程。在课上，戴夫谈到了日常生活产生的挑战实际上
made up of two entirely different kinds of problems. One kind is tame, and the other is what he calls wicked. Maintain problem is one you know how to solve. A wicked problem is one where the criteria are changing all the time, even if you come up with a solution you don't get to reuse it over and over again, the status of what you're working on changes constantly and never is stable, problems like, you know, education and poverty and your own life or raising a kid So wicked problems are particularly good for the method of design thinking because design relies on the empirical process of iterating multiple ideas with prototypes so going out into reality, not just into your head, and trying something out.
由两种完全不同的问题组成。一种是“温和问题”，另一种是他所说的“邪恶问题”。温和问题是你懂得如何解决的问题。邪恶问题是指标准一直在变化的问题，即使你提出了一个解决方案，你也不能反复使用它，你所处理的状态在不断变化，从不保持稳定，比如教育、贫困、你自己的生活或抚养孩子等问题。所以，邪恶问题特别适合设计思维方法，因为设计依赖于通过原型迭代多个想法的经验过程，即走进现实，而不仅仅是在脑子里想，并尝试一些事情。
So, solving these two different kinds of problems requires two different approaches. When you can't know what you're doing, you can't navigate, like a GPS would, because you don't have a map and you don't have all the information, you have to waive find, and waive finding means taking one step at a time, knowing something about the direction you're going, trying a few things, you know, tuning it up and then doing it again and doing it again. And life is like that. Like lots of other well-educated and competent people, Christine is a good navigator.
所以，解决这两种不同的问题需要两种不同的方法。当你不知道自己在做什么时，你不能像使用GPS那样导航，因为你没有地图，也没有所有信息，你必须进行“寻路”。寻路意味着一步一个脚印，了解你前进的方向，尝试一些事情，进行调整，然后再做一次，再做一次。生活就是这样。像许多其他受过良好教育且有能力的人一样，克里斯汀是一位优秀的导航员。
The reason she feels paralyzed is that the problem she's facing isn't one of navigation, but wayfinding. Dave's students often have the same dilemma. Everyone turns out to be pretty interested in what they're doing with their life, and nobody was given a toolkit for how to figure that out. Wayfinding isn't just about finding out where you need to go. It's about getting comfortable with the idea that you may not have just one destination. where you need to go. It's about getting comfortable with the idea that you may not have just one destination. When students come to Dave and tell him they're worried they do not know what to do with their lives,
她感到瘫痪的原因是她面临的问题不是导航问题，而是寻路问题。戴夫的学生经常有同样的困境。事实证明，每个人都对自己的人生方向很感兴趣，但没有人得到过如何弄清楚这一点的工具包。寻路不仅仅是找出你需要去哪里。它是关于适应这样一个想法：你可能不止有一个目的地。它是关于适应这样一个想法：你可能不止有一个目的地。当学生来到戴夫面前，告诉他他们担心不知道该如何度过一生时，
he tells them, there's more than one of you in there. So there are many more than one right answer to what your life looks like. So the problem with the current approach that lots of people are taking is it starts with the wrong question. And the wrong question is, how do I figure out that one best solution to my life?
他告诉他们：“你内心不止有一个你。”所以，关于你的人生是什么样子的，正确答案不止一个。因此，许多人目前采取的方法的问题在于，它从错误的问题开始。错误的问题是：“我该如何找出我人生中那个唯一的最佳解决方案？”
There is one exclusive, unique, optimal version of me, and I'm supposed to already know it, and I'm probably already late, and how do I figure it out, and how would I know if I knew, how can I be sure? And we think all those questions are the wrong questions. So this is the guy Christine turned to for help. She went to a workshop Dave was running in New York, and he asked her and the other participants to do a series of different exercises
“存在一个排他的、独特的、最优版本的我，我应该已经知道了，而且我可能已经迟到了，我该如何弄清楚它，如果我知道了，我怎么能确定，我怎么能确信？”我们认为所有这些问题都是错误的问题。所以这就是克里斯汀求助的人。她参加了戴夫在纽约举办的一个研讨会，他要求她和其他参与者进行一系列不同的练习，
to apply design thinking to whatever problem they felt stuck on. One of the exercises is what Dave calls Odyssey Planning. The principle behind the Odyssey Planning exercise is that there isn't just one career or one life plan for any of us. Dave asks everyone to give. Three completely different variations of the next five years of your life. We've already said we're pretty sure there are lots of you in there. There's lots of Sean Cars who could be, you're having a great time being a public radio host and doing really interesting work of the hidden brain. But if I suddenly said, you know, the radio world just died, Sean car, that's over completely.
将设计思维应用到他们感到困境的任何问题上。其中一个练习是戴夫所说的“奥德赛规划”。奥德赛规划练习背后的原则是，我们每个人都没有唯一的职业或人生计划。戴夫要求每个人给出未来五年生活的三个完全不同的变体。我们已经说过，我们很确定你内心有很多个你。有很多个尚卡尔，你可以享受作为公共广播主持人的时光，并做着《隐藏的大脑》中非常有趣的工作。但如果我突然说：“尚卡尔，广播界刚刚消亡了，那一切都结束了。”
You have to do something else. Well, you wouldn't just sit on the lawn waiting for time to go by. You'd go do something else. There are other things you could do. So we have people come up with three completely different versions of themselves, and then go try some prototypes in each of them so that what you end up with is not just the one perfect life,
“你必须做点别的。”好吧，你不会只是坐在草坪上等待时间流逝。你会去做别的事情。还有其他你可以做的事情。所以我们让人们想出三个完全不同的自己，然后在每一个版本中尝试一些原型，这样你最终得到的不仅仅是那一个完美的生活，
but recognizing there are many lives I could have and now I'm going to choose the one that I'm going to have. It's gonna be a good life, it could even be a great life, but it doesn't have to be exclusively good. It's just the good life I'm going to have. It's gonna be a good life, it could even be a great life, but it doesn't have to be exclusively good. It's just the good life I'm living now. Think of these life prototypes like a mouse with one button and a mouse with two buttons. Interestingly, when we do these Odyssey plans
而是认识到我可能拥有许多种生活，现在我要选择我将要拥有的那一种。这将是美好的生活，甚至可能是伟大的生活，但它不必是唯一的选择。它只是我将要拥有的美好生活。这将是美好的生活，甚至可能是伟大的生活，但它不必是唯一的选择。它只是我正在过的美好生活。把这些生活原型想象成一个带一个按钮的鼠标和一个带两个按钮的鼠标。有趣的是，当我们制定这些奥德赛计划时，
and people now have three plans in front of them that are quite different, you'd think that possibly what that does is give people even more reason to be disappointed and dismayed, like now we know exactly what I don't get to do. I've actually written down, you know, two things I'm not gonna have time to live into. What a drag is that?
人们现在面前有三个截然不同的计划，你可能会认为这只会让人们更有理由感到失望和沮丧，就像“现在我确切地知道我无法实现什么了。我实际上写下了两件我没时间去过的事情。这多扫兴啊？”
And exactly the opposite occurs. What happens is when you lay out three ideas that you might be able to live into and then said, well, if I really have to pick one because I can't be three people at once, I'm going with planet. So after people have the chance to articulate to themselves what their real alternatives are,
结果却恰恰相反。发生的情况是，当你列出三个你可能能够去过的想法，然后说：“好吧，如果我真的必须选一个，因为我不能同时成为三个人，我选计划一。”所以，在人们有机会向自己阐明他们真正的选择是什么之后，
they feel better about the choice they're making. That's completely in contrast to this, are you sure you're doing the right thing? You haven't settled, have you? Is this really your passion? These questions that have such an incredibly unrealistic demand of hitting this high bar. That question, you can never answer perfectly. Are you really passionate enough?
他们对自己所做的选择感觉更好。这与“你确定你做的是对的吗？”、“你还没安定下来吧？”、“这真的是你的热情所在吗？”这些问题完全相反。这些问题对达到这个高标准有着极其不切实际的要求。那个问题，你永远无法完美回答。你真的足够热情吗？
I mean, who knows if they are. Are you sure that is it? The unknown competitor that you haven't had a chance to think up yet is a vicious antagonist to your peace and happiness in life. Once you realize, none of us knows the future, we're making it up as we go along, so let's get really good at making it up as we go along. In fact, let's design it as we go along.
我是说，谁知道自己是否足够热情呢？你确定就是它了吗？那个你还没来得及想到的未知竞争对手，是你生活中平静与幸福的恶毒对手。一旦你意识到，我们谁都不知道未来，我们是在边走边编，那么让我们变得非常擅长边走边编吧。事实上，让我们在前进的过程中设计它。
That turns out to work much more effectively. Now there are many things in our lives we just can't control. Like Christine not being able to get a work visa or being laid off from her job. People often spend years feeling frustrated about their constraints. Let's say for example you dream of being a musician, but no one will pay you to do that. Dave Evans says, that's a gravity problem. And a gravity problem is a very specific class of problem. I happen to be a cyclist, and I'm getting older,
事实证明，这更有效。现在，我们生活中有很多事情是我们无法控制的。比如克里斯汀无法获得工作签证或被解雇。人们经常花几年时间对自己的限制感到沮丧。假设你梦想成为一名音乐家，但没有人愿意为此付钱给你。戴夫·埃文斯说，那是一个“重力问题”。重力问题是一类非常具体的问题。我恰好是一名骑行者，而且我年纪大了，
so I'm doing that thing of putting on a little lecture weight and it's starting to bother me. So if I said chunkar, I've got this terrible problem. It's gravity. It's making me crazy. It's slowing me down. It's ruining my bicycle ride. It's getting worse with time.
所以我开始增加一点体重，这开始困扰我。所以如果我说：“尚卡尔，我有一个可怕的问题。是重力。它让我发疯。它让我慢下来。它毁了我的自行车骑行。它随着时间的推移变得越来越糟。”
I've got to do something about it. Can you help me? And you just look at me and kind of go, no, David, it's not a problem, it's a problem, what do you want me to do? But a lot of people are in fact dealing with a problem that's just like gravity. Again, design is oriented to action. One of our minds that says bias to action, when When did out do something, which means if you can't do anything about it, if it's not actionable, it's not a problem.
“我必须对此做点什么。你能帮我吗？”你只会看着我，然后说：“不，戴夫，这不是问题，这是重力，你想让我做什么？”但很多人实际上正在处理一个就像重力一样的问题。同样，设计是面向行动的。我们的一种思维方式是“行动偏见”，即当你不知道该做什么时，就去做点什么，这意味着如果你对此无能为力，如果它不可操作，那它就不是问题。
It's a circumstance. And a lot of people have a problem that isn't a problem. It's just a circumstance. So let's say the problem is you can't make any money as a professional musician. Unless you're in the top 1 1 1 1 1 percent, which yet now that I'm 37 years old and frankly only nominally talented at doing this thing, my chances of attaining are about zero.
它是一种环境。很多人遇到的问题根本不是问题。它只是一个环境。所以假设问题是你无法作为职业音乐家赚到钱。除非你是那前1%的人，而现在我已经37岁了，坦率地说，在这方面只有名义上的天赋，我实现这一目标的几率为零。
That's not a problem. That's a fact. People get stuck on the wrong policy. How do I, how can I make a living and keep my mortgage paid by being a musician? That is not an actionable problem. Once you accept your gravity problem, as in fact, not a problem, but a circumstance, maybe a difficult one, maybe a heartbreaking one,
那不是问题。那是事实。人们被错误的策略困住了。“我该如何通过成为一名音乐家来谋生并支付抵押贷款？”这不是一个可操作的问题。一旦你接受了你的重力问题，实际上它不是一个问题，而是一个环境，也许是一个困难的环境，也许是一个令人心碎的环境，
but once you realize it's just a fact, you free yourself to go do something you can do. So once I've decided, oh, I'm never gonna be able to make this income as a musician. That's not a problem, it's just an awful fact. Now what do I do? Well, I have two different paths I can go right off the bat. I can say, great, how can I learn how to live on
但一旦你意识到它只是一个事实，你就解放了自己，可以去做你能做的事情。所以一旦我决定，“哦，我永远无法作为音乐家赚到这种收入。”那不是问题，它只是一个糟糕的事实。现在我该怎么办？好吧，我立刻就有两条不同的路径可以走。我可以想：“太好了，我该如何学习如何靠
$15,000 a year and feed my family of three? Obviously not in this house, while being a rising starving musician. And I can actually figure out how to do that. I know people who successfully do. Or I could ask the question, since I'm never going to get to be a professional musician, how can I craft a lifestyle that keeps my income going while making my application, the thing I do for love not money,
每年1.5万美元生活并养活我三口之家？”显然不是在这所房子里，同时还要做一个冉冉升起的饥饿音乐家。我实际上可以弄清楚如何做到这一点。我认识成功做到这一点的人。或者我可以问这个问题：“既然我永远无法成为一名职业音乐家，我该如何打造一种生活方式，既能维持我的收入，又能让我的爱好——音乐，成为我为爱而非为钱所做的事情，
called music, as satisfying as possible. That's a life I could design. This is the heart of design thinking. It isn't about becoming your perfect self. It's about looking very honestly at your circumstances and asking what room you have to maneuver. Think about those designers in Silicon Valley. They're always releasing programs in beta.
并尽可能地令人满意？”那是我可以设计的生活。这就是设计思维的核心。它不是关于成为完美的自己。它是关于非常诚实地审视你的环境，并询问你有什么回旋余地。想想硅谷的那些设计师。他们总是发布测试版程序。
The idea is you try something very practical and very doable, something that you can do quickly, send it out into the world, and then learn from how it performs. You come back, iterate, and then go back to the world again. This is Dave's idea about how you should design your life. Rather than sitting around thinking about what would be ideal, try a series of experiments, learn from them.
这个想法是，你尝试一些非常实用且可行的事情，一些你可以快速完成的事情，把它推向世界，然后从它的表现中学习。你回来，迭代，然后再回到世界。这就是戴夫关于你应该如何设计生活的想法。与其坐着思考什么是理想的，不如尝试一系列实验，从中学习。
And here's the important thing. Keep doing this indefinitely. There is no perfect you, but there's probably a better you that is achievable. Designers aren't necessarily more creative than everybody else, but they are better at getting unstuck. Christine Metzger says this idea really helped her think about her problem differently. There is not just one right job for you. And I think for most of my life I had that sense of when I'm looking for work or if I was in a transition,
这里重要的一点是：无限期地这样做。没有完美的你，但可能有一个可实现的更好的你。设计师并不一定比其他人更有创造力，但他们更擅长摆脱困境。克里斯汀·梅茨格说，这个想法确实帮助她以不同的方式思考她的问题。“没有唯一适合你的工作。我想我一生中大部分时间都有这种感觉，当我在找工作或处于过渡期时，
I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. And we talked in the class about how there's so much potential in each person and you have so many different skills and talents in the way you're wired, that there's not just one thing that you can do, but there are many. Abandoning the idea of finding her idea life was liberating. I really like this idea with design thinking about what can I do in the next two weeks that
我给自己施加了很大的压力，以确保我做出了完全正确的决定。”我们在课上讨论过，每个人身上都有如此多的潜力，你有许多不同的技能和天赋，以至于你不仅能做一件事，而是能做很多事。放弃寻找理想生活的想法是一种解脱。我真的很喜欢设计思维中关于“我可以在接下来的两周内做些什么”的想法，
can give me some new information. That just seemed really doable. And I think that's important when you're trying to make decisions or get unstuck that you're not thinking about, oh, I just have to figure everything out perfectly, but in fact I liked what he said about, with design thinking your goal is to fail early and often. When we come back, we look at another example of design thinking. A writer who felt she'd lost her way, but then found a new path forward. I was raised, you know, right every day, right 1500 words a day,
这能给我一些新的信息。这看起来真的很可行。我认为当你试图做决定或摆脱困境时，这一点很重要，你不是在想“哦，我必须把一切都弄得完美”，事实上，我喜欢他说的关于设计思维的目标是“尽早且频繁地失败”。回来后，我们将看看设计思维的另一个例子。一位觉得自己迷失了方向，但随后找到了新前进道路的作家。我从小就被教导，你知道，每天写，每天写1500字，
go to graduate school, rewrite, rewrite, rewrite, and this was never a way to write that was given to me, I really did just sort of make it up. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We started today with Christine Metzkar, who sought out design thinking to help her get unstuck. Next, we'll hear from someone who exemplified design thinking without even knowing it. Our producer Maggie Penman has the story.
去读研究生，重写，重写，再重写，这从来不是一种给我的写作方式，我真的是自己编出来的。请留下来。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们今天从克里斯汀·梅茨格开始，她寻求设计思维来帮助她摆脱困境。接下来，我们将听到一位在不知不觉中践行了设计思维的人的故事。我们的制作人玛吉·彭曼有这个故事。
Helen Ellis grew up in Tuscallusa, Alabama, dreaming of being a writer. In her mind, being a serious writer, moving to New York. So at 22 years old, that's what she did. I came to New York dressed in Alabama's finest at the time, which was Talbot's, a full-planned ankle length skirt and turtleneck. And I went from publishing, has to publishing, has trying to get a job in publishing. No one would hire me. And I ended up getting a job at Talbotts. Helen worked in retail for a few years and then as a secretary, but she kept her eyes on her goal.
海伦·埃利斯在阿拉巴马州的塔斯卡卢萨长大，梦想成为一名作家。在她看来，成为一名严肃的作家意味着搬到纽约。所以22岁时，她就这样做了。我穿着当时阿拉巴马州最好的衣服来到纽约，那是Talbots品牌的，一条全褶及踝长裙和高领毛衣。我一家出版社一家出版社地跑，试图找一份出版工作。没人愿意雇我。最后我在Talbots找到了一份工作。海伦在零售业工作了几年，然后当了秘书，但她一直盯着自己的目标。
Finally, she got her big break. She got into NYU's creative writing program off the wait list and started writing her first novel. And it was like a dream. I came out of graduate school. I sold the book within a year. It was a nice sum of money. It did very well. Helen was just 29.
终于，她迎来了重大突破。她从候补名单中进入了纽约大学的创意写作项目，并开始写她的第一部小说。那就像一场梦。我从研究生院毕业。我在一年内卖掉了这本书。那是一笔不错的钱。它卖得很好。海伦当时才29岁。
She was living in Manhattan and she was a published author. She had arrived. She immediately started working on her next book. But no one wanted to publish it. I think it was about a poker playing serial killer. She wrote another book about a 19th century prostitute in Mississippi. Nobody wanted to publish that either. She decided the problem was that she wasn't focusing enough on writing, so she quit her day
她住在曼哈顿，是一位已出版作品的作家。她成功了。她立即开始写下一本书。但没人愿意出版它。我想那是一本关于扑克牌连环杀手的书。她又写了一本关于密西西比州19世纪妓女的书。也没人愿意出版。她认为问题在于她没有足够专注于写作，所以她辞掉了白天
job and doubled down on being a full-time writer. She wrote another book, and again, couldn't get it published. I just didn't write anything good enough. Helen put the manuscripts away in a drawer, and then I quit, and nobody cared. Honestly, all that happens is she put on 10 pounds. Helen felt like a failure.
的工作，全身心投入到全职写作中。她又写了一本书，结果还是没能出版。我只是没写出足够好的东西。海伦把手稿放进抽屉里，然后我放弃了，没人关心。老实说，发生的一切只是她胖了10磅。海伦觉得自己是个失败者。
Like, maybe she wasn't meant to be a writer after all. Having quit her day job and now writing to empty days stretched out before her. But Helen is not the kind of person who was content to do nothing. As it turns out, Helen likes to cook and clean and decorate, so she became in her words, a housewife. And through herself into it. It's art. Yeah, it really is. Helen may not have used this word to describe what she was doing, but she was wayfinding. She turned her entire Manhattan apartment into a masterpiece of whimsy.
就像，也许她根本就不是当作家的料。辞掉了白天的工作，现在写作，空虚的日子在她面前延伸。但海伦不是那种满足于无所事事的人。事实证明，海伦喜欢烹饪、打扫和装饰，所以她用她的话说，成了一名“家庭主妇”。并全身心投入其中。这是艺术。是的，确实是。海伦可能没有用这个词来描述她正在做的事情，但她正在“寻路”。她把整个曼哈顿的公寓变成了一件异想天开的杰作。
She put up flamingo wallpaper in the entryway and had a little flamingo painted on the next wall as if he escaped the wallpaper and strutted around the corner. Sort of a tribute to flamingos in the front yard where I grew up. She got the most amazing refrigerator. It's bright orange and looks like something straight off the set of madmen. When I went to visit her, it was one of the first things I noticed. Oh, love the fridge. Thank you.
她在入口处贴了火烈鸟壁纸，并在旁边的墙上画了一只小火烈鸟，仿佛它逃出了壁纸，在拐角处大摇大摆地走着。算是对我成长过程中前院火烈鸟的一种致敬。她买了一个最棒的冰箱。它是亮橙色的，看起来就像直接从《广告狂人》片场拿出来的一样。我去拜访她时，这是我注意到的第一件事。“哦，喜欢这个冰箱。”“谢谢。”
It's my, some people have dream jewelry, and I had a dream fridge. That's perfect. And if you care to poke around in her medicine cabinet, which Helen insists everyone does, you'll find little bits of humor and color there too. Well, there's a gnome. There's a 1940s kitty cat planter filled with cotton balls.
“这是我的……有些人有梦想珠宝，而我有梦想冰箱。”“那太完美了。”如果你想翻翻她的药柜，海伦坚持每个人都应该这样做，你也会在那里发现一点幽默和色彩。嗯，有一个小矮人。有一个装满棉球的1940年代小猫花盆。
And it's, of course, arranged by color. Of course. But even as she collected art and records and antiques, she was sometimes reminded of the dream she had given up. And I would go places with my husband and people would ask me, what do you do? And I would say, honestly, I'm a housewife. And the next question they would ask if there was another question was,
而且，当然，是按颜色排列的。“当然。”但即使在她收集艺术品、唱片和古董时，她有时也会想起她放弃的梦想。我会和丈夫一起去某些地方，人们会问我：“你是做什么的？”我会说：“老实说，我是个家庭主妇。”如果还有下一个问题，他们会问的下一个问题是：
what do you do all day? After getting that question one too many times, Helen came up with an answer in the form of a snarky Twitter account. She called it, what I do all day. I just started tweeting about my life, funny little things, and as I gained more followers, I gained confidence again.
“你整天都在做什么？”在被问到这个问题太多次后，海伦以一个刻薄的推特账号的形式给出了答案。她称之为“我整天都在做什么”。我开始在推特上发布关于我生活的有趣小事，随着粉丝的增加，我再次获得了信心。
Helen's Twitter persona is like a 1950s housewife on steroids. She tweets things like, women doubt, dust, or my idea of crushing it is making a graham crack or crust. Her Twitter account also includes plenty of translation of what Helen calls Southern Lady Code, which she describes as,
海伦的推特形象就像一个打了兴奋剂的1950年代家庭主妇。她发布这样的内容：“女性怀疑，灰尘，或者我所谓的‘搞定它’的想法就是做一个全麦饼干皮。”她的推特账号还包括大量对海伦所说的“南方淑女密码”的翻译，她将其描述为：
if you don't have something nice to say, say something that's so nice in a nice way. Like her Instagram is very curated. Is Southern Lady Code for, she is a hot or miss, then spaghetti and meatballs and a clothes dryer. Her Twitter account became increasingly popular. People loved her self-deprecating humor and related to the daily struggles of
“如果你没有什么好话可说，那就用一种非常好的方式说一些非常好的话。”比如她的Instagram非常精心策划。“这是南方淑女密码，意思是：她是个失败者，然后是意大利面和肉丸以及干衣机。”她的推特账号越来越受欢迎。人们喜欢她自嘲的幽默，并与日常的挣扎产生共鸣，比如
cooking and cleaning and laundry. And there was another benefit too. Little by little, tweet by tweet, she was writing again, 140 characters at a time. It got me unstuck. It really did. Even better, her followers gave her instant feedback, telling her which ideas were funny and which jokes fell flat. I found that Twitter was an excellent editor, so if I tweeted something and it wasn't retweeted in say 20 minutes, it's deleted. Tweeting allowed Helen to just throw something out there.
烹饪、打扫和洗衣服。还有一个好处。一点一点地，一条推文接一条推文，她又开始写作了，每次140个字符。它让我摆脱了困境。真的。更好的是，她的粉丝给了她即时反馈，告诉她哪些想法很有趣，哪些笑话很冷场。我发现推特是一个出色的编辑，所以如果我发了什么东西，20分钟内没有被转发，它就会被删除。发推文让海伦可以随意抛出一些东西。
See if it stuck. In the language of design thinking, she was prototyping. I had gone about writing in a very structured traditional way for my entire life. You know, writing 1500 words a day, going to graduate school, having a full-time job, writing in the morning. If this doesn't work, write another one. If this doesn't work, write another one in the same way. And I think it was, well, I know it was breaking that pattern that helped me find my voice again. When she had enough tweets to fill a book or even two, she printed them all out to see what was there.
看看它是否能引起共鸣。用设计思维的语言来说，她是在进行原型设计。我一生中一直以一种非常结构化、传统的方式写作。你知道，每天写1500字，去读研究生，有一份全职工作，早上写作。如果这行不通，再写一本。如果这行不通，以同样的方式再写一本。我想，嗯，我知道是打破那种模式帮助我重新找到了自己的声音。当她有足够的推文来填满一本书甚至两本书时，她把它们全部打印出来看看有什么。
A few themes emerged. Love and marriage, dinner parties, cutting commentary about housework, her neighbors, and her two cats. So she did something she had been trying to do for years. She wrote another book and got it published. A book of short stories inspired by her tweets. It was called American Housewife. After years of trying to write books that I thought other people would want to read that were never published, I thought, maybe I'll write what I know. I had 10 years under my belt and I thought, well, there is nothing more unpredictable than a woman
出现了几个主题：爱情与婚姻、晚宴、关于家务的尖刻评论、她的邻居和她的两只猫。所以她做了她多年来一直试图做的事情。她写了另一本书并出版了。一本受她推文启发的小故事集。书名叫《美国主妇》。在尝试写我认为别人想读却从未出版的书多年后，我想，也许我会写我所知道的。我有10年的经验，我想，嗯，没有什么比一个女人更不可预测的了
left alone in her home all day long. Let's explore that. The first story in the collection is called What I Do All Day. And that story is made up probably 96% of tweets that I tweeted over three years and then cobbled together and people always say every other line is just a killer and it's because Twitter was my editor you know if it's not retweeted it it's deleted. So every sentence in that story was retweeted or applauded or approved. And it was just this new way to write. When Helen was 29 and had just published
整天独自留在家里。让我们探索一下。集子里的第一个故事叫《我整天都在做什么》。那个故事大概由我三年来发布的96%的推文组成，然后拼凑在一起，人们总是说每一行都是杀手锏，这是因为推特是我的编辑，你知道，如果它没有被转发，它就会被删除。所以那个故事里的每一句话都被转发、鼓掌或认可。这只是一种新的写作方式。当海伦29岁，刚刚出版
a successful literary novel, she felt tremendous pressure to write the perfect second book. But now in her 40s, having failed so many times, she looks at things differently. I mean, one of the nice things about the failure and saying that I was a housewife and having the anonymous account was nobody knew it was me, nobody was watching, there were absolutely no expectations, and it really freed me. And I had been able to, as of, you know, today keep hold of that.
了一部成功的小说时，她感到写出完美第二本书的巨大压力。但现在40多岁了，在失败了这么多次之后，她以不同的方式看待事物。我的意思是，失败的好处之一，以及说我是家庭主妇并拥有匿名账号，就是没人知道是我，没人盯着，完全没有任何期望，这真的解放了我。而且，正如你所知，直到今天，我一直能够保持这种状态。
Her second book has done very well. I had been able to, as you know, today keep hold of that. Her second book has done very well, but if it hadn't, I really would have been fine. So, and it was 15 years between books, I really don't feel the pressure until I'm 60. Helen Ellis speaking with producer Maggie Penman. Many of us feel stuck, stuck at work, stuck in the wrong city, stuck in life. When that happens, we often end up asking ourselves,
她的第二本书卖得很好。正如你所知，直到今天，我一直能够保持这种状态。她的第二本书卖得很好，但如果没卖好，我真的也会没事的。所以，两本书之间隔了15年，我真的在60岁之前感觉不到压力。海伦·埃利斯与制作人玛吉·彭曼的对话。我们许多人感到停滞不前，在工作中停滞不前，在错误的城市停滞不前，在生活中停滞不前。当这种情况发生时，我们经常最终问自己：
what should I do? Where should I live? What's my ideal life? It turns out, these normal questions are counterproductive to getting us unstuck. They place an unbearable pressure on us, the pressure to know how things are supposed to turn out. The next time that happens to you, think of your life, the way a designer at a tech company, things of a new product. You don't quite know what you want to build. Just for fun, you come up with a prototype, then a second and a third. You pay attention to whether you enjoy building one kind of prototype or another. You listen to feedback from others. You go back to the drawing board and try again. When someone asks you, years later, how you knew what you wanted to be, you can tell them, honestly, I didn't. Hidden Brain is produced by Maggie Penman, Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins,
“我该做什么？我该住在哪里？我理想的生活是什么？”事实证明，这些正常的问题对我们摆脱困境适得其反。它们给我们施加了无法承受的压力，即必须知道事情应该如何发展的压力。下次这种情况发生在你身上时，像科技公司的设计师思考新产品那样思考你的生活。你并不完全知道你想建造什么。为了好玩，你提出了一个原型，然后是第二个和第三个。你关注自己是否喜欢建造某种原型。你倾听他人的反馈。你回到绘图板重新尝试。多年后，当有人问你是怎么知道自己想成为什么样的人时，你可以诚实地告诉他们：“老实说，我不知道。”《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·彭曼、詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、露西·珀金斯制作，
and Parth Shah. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our team also includes Rene Clar, who does great videos and illustrations for our Facebook, Instagram, and Twitter accounts. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend who doesn't know about our show. Tell us whom you've tapped on social media, we want more people to find our show. Our unsung hero this week is Tanya Blue. Tanya works in NPR's development department and she got us unstuck as we were getting this project off the ground. It takes money to build great audio, so if you think you can write a check with a few zeros, please drop Tanya Align at tblueatNPR.org.
以及帕斯·沙阿。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。我们的团队还包括雷内·克拉尔，他为我们的Facebook、Instagram和推特账号制作了很棒的视频和插图。如果你喜欢这一集，请分享给不知道我们节目的朋友。告诉我们你在社交媒体上推荐了谁，我们希望更多人找到我们的节目。我们本周的无名英雄是坦尼娅·布鲁。坦尼娅在NPR的发展部门工作，当我们启动这个项目时，她帮助我们摆脱了困境。制作出色的音频需要资金，所以如果你认为你可以写一张带有几个零的支票，请给坦尼娅发邮件：tblue@npr.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。